yesterday was the first day of spring so
it's time to talk new water conservation
rules with the southern nevada water
authority the sponsors of this next
segment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm jc davis i'm the manager of
enterprise conservation for the southern
nevada water authority uh we're the part
of the organization that works with
non-residential customers whether
they're commercial properties like this
one or homeowners association or
apartment complexes
and
we're focused at this moment on what's
called assembly bill 356
which is a new state law
that is going to prohibit irrigation
of non-functional turf by the end of
2026 using colorado river water
so our
our focus is in trying to help these
customers
remove that turf and replace it with
drip irrigated landscapes which use
about 75 percent less water one of the
things that we're doing to try to help
customers make the transition is we
actually offer incentive money
for them to make the replacement of the
grass
with drip irrigated landscapes so we pay
three dollars a square foot for the
first 10 000 square feet and then a
dollar fifty a square foot thereafter
with no cap so while single family
residents aren't subject to this new law
so they don't have to take out their
turf a lot of them want to and in fact
we're seeing epic numbers in terms of
participation in our water smart
landscapes rebate program so we want to
make things as easy as possible on our
customers so we have a variety of
resources available for them everything
from sample landscape designs for
residential properties to a an updated
plant list of plants that do really well
in this climate to even a list of
qualified contractors that have
completed training with us so that we
know that they're going to be able to do
the job correctly so as of march 1st the
spring watering schedule came into
effect so people can water up to three
days a week on their assigned days
but if you have a drip irrigated
landscape already you don't need to for
this time of year until the temps kind
of break into the 80s and low 90s two
days a week is just fine for a drip
landscape and so you'll save water your
plants will actually be healthier for it
if people don't know what their watering
group is and what days they're supposed
to water they can go to snwa.com
they can get information about the
watering schedule and all of the other
things that i mentioned so this year
because of the colorado river drought
we're taking a seven billion gallon
shortage to our already small allocation
and so we can't afford to use water on
purely non-functional grass and things
like that um you know our focus is not
to reduce anybody's quality of life or
drive customers away from people's
businesses but rather to just make sure
we're making the best use of the water
we have
thank you again to southern nevada water
authority for sponsoring this segment
for more information call 702 258 save
or visit snwa.com